foreign
[Music]
I'm Melissa and today I'm going to be
talking about how to achieve a seamless
workflow between R Python and SAS all
from within our studio
now we're at an R Studio conference and
more specifically right now we're in a
session that's called some of my best
friends use python
so I already know that everyone in this
room loves at least three of the words
that are in the title of my talk
but before we talk about r or python I
first want to take a moment to talk
about something that I know we're all
even more passionate about which of
course is SAS
don't worry I'm totally kidding I was
not referring to sass here at all I was
actually talking about food
and I apologize in advance because I
know we're still about an hour away from
our lunch break today but I do just want
to take a moment to talk about food
before we go any further
I love food but I'm not a very good cook
so I really like these meal kit boxes
that you can get delivered to your door
because the recipes are always super
straightforward and they always come
with the exact right ingredients
measured out in the exact right
proportions
and usually if I follow along with the
steps in the recipe and one of these
meal kit boxes I can get the results to
look pretty close to the pictures that
are in the recipe
but there's just one problem with these
meal kit boxes and that problem is that
they give bad cooks like me
false confidence
these meal kit boxes have me thinking
that I'm totally capable of recreating
these masterpieces totally on my own but
a few weeks later if I try to reproduce
the food I don't have all of the
ingredients available and suddenly I
have to start making some substitutions
and all of a sudden my food can end up
looking a little more something like
this
and I find that the same can be said for
a lot of programming tutorials
if you have all of the right ingredients
measured out in the exact rate
proportions then it's pretty easy to
follow along with a simple recipe and
get the desired results
but if you're missing some key
ingredients then you start having to
make some substitutions or find some
workarounds and then you'll end up with
something that's perhaps technically
edible although certainly less than
ideal
and that leads me to the outline for my
talk today I'm going to be discussing
how to incorporate these three languages
into your workflow but I'm going to
present it in two different ways
the first way is an ideal approach and
this approach is going to be kind of
like following along with a simple
three-step recipe where but the downside
here is that I'm going to assume that
you have all of the ingredients
available
and the second way that I'll present is
a less than ideal approach where you're
missing some key ingredients and so you
have to find some workarounds
but before I jump into that I first want
to start by providing some context as to
why this particular challenge arose for
me
I'm an analyst at statistics Canada
which for those who are unfamiliar is an
agency within the government of Canada
and statistics Canada is Canada's
official statistical agency
and the particular challenge that I face
at work is that my employer wants to
adopt open source programming languages
like R and python
but we have a legal responsibility to
ensure that personal information
collected for statistical purposes is
kept strictly confidential
this means that when we publish
statistics we first need to use an
internal generalized system called
g-confid which is a series of SAS macros
that prevents the release of
confidential information in tabular data
using cell suppression and controlled
random rounding methods
and g-confid is only implemented in the
SAS programming language
and what this means in practice is that
many analysts and data scientists at
statistics Canada
have to use SAS as part of their
workflow if they want to be able to
publish official statistics
my typical workflow at statcan usually
looks a little bit something like this
I work with some SAS data sets that
first get passed through some
pre-written pre-processing scripts that
are written in sauce
and once the data are ready to be
analyzed I bring the data into R and
then I do the vast majority of my
analysis in r
but if I want those results to be
publishable then I need to bring the
data from our back into SAS so that I
can use these g-config macros
and you can think of G config kind of
like a black box it's a series of SAS
macros that is completely uneditable by
me and these macros are themselves
confidential
so I cannot and I would not want to
implement G config in any other
programming language
so for this step I really do need to use
SAS
once I'm finished with G config I bring
those results back into R for data
visualization purposes
and as you can see my workflow really
does require me to be able to go back
and forth between SAS and R seamlessly
and while I myself don't typically use
Python at work I do have a lot of
colleagues who would appreciate the
ability to incorporate it into their
workflow
so all of this led me to the question
is there a way to combine these three
languages in the same script in a way
that does not cause a headache
and the answer is yes and there are
multiple different approaches
the most straightforward approach is a
simple three-step recipe
and step one of this recipe is to gather
your required ingredients
for this particular recipe the required
ingredients are the languages that
you're interested in using plus Java
and the other ingredient that's not
pictured here but which really is the
most important ingredient for making
this particular recipe succeed is admin
privileges and if you don't have admin
privileges on your computer you might
not be able to get this recipe to work
step two of this three-step recipe
assuming you have all of those required
ingredients from Step One is to install
SAS Pi which is a python package that
works very similarly to how reticulate
works
so just like reticulate is an R
interface to python
SAS Pi is a python interface to SAS
the third and final step of this
three-step recipe is to perform a couple
of system configurations
and there's a lot of little details that
are in this step so I won't go over that
today for the sake of time but if you're
interested in following along there is a
video on my YouTube channel that
explains all the steps and includes an
example usage of combining these three
languages in the same script using SAS
pi
now that was definitely the most
straightforward approach and the
recommended well my personal recommended
way of how to achieve this workflow but
if you have limited control over your
computer then it might not be possible
for you
so in the next few slides I'm going to
present a few alternative approaches
that will allow you to combine SAS and R
in the same script and sometimes python
the approach that you choose is going to
defend heavily on what you need to do
and on how much control you have over
your computer
and for the three alternative options
that I'm about to present there's for
all three of them there's going to be a
big trade-off between complexity and
usefulness
the first option is to use the SAS
markdown package which as you might be
able to guess from the name is a package
that allows you to include SAS chunks in
your R markdown or Cordo documents
this option has the benefit of not
requiring admin privileges but the
downside is that there's no interaction
between SAS and R at all so what this
means is that the SAS data sets that you
define in your SAS chunks are not going
to be accessible to you in your R chunks
and vice versa
for me personally I really need this
interoperability between these two
languages so this particular option
isn't the most useful for me but this
package does have some really
interesting use cases
for example if you're a course
instructor you could use this in order
to show your students how to perform the
same task using multiple different
programming languages all in the same
place
once you have the SAS markdown package
installed it's fairly easy to switch
between the three languages within your
R markdown or Corridor documents and all
you need to do is specify which language
you'd like to use in each individual
code chunk
if you want to use sauce just set the
engine option to be SAS HTML
and you can set the engine.path option
to be the file path to your SAS
executable
to use R leave the chunk header as the
default
and to use Python set the chunk header
to say python
and if you were to knit an R markdown
document that contains three chunks that
looks like this the result will be
something that looks like
this
the second approach that you can use is
a SAS first approach rather than an R
first approach
when SAS is launched there's an option
that you can enable which is called
rlang and the arlang that you see there
on the slide in all caps I should
mention has absolutely no relationship
to the r Lang package in R so this all
caps are laying that you see here is a
SAS concept not in our concept
the rlang option can be enabled without
admin privileges and it's pretty easy to
move data back and forth between SAS and
R using this method which makes this
option quite a bit more useful than the
SAS markdown package for my purposes at
least
once the rlang option is enabled you can
use proc IML in SAS to execute our code
and in order to execute that R code just
use a submit statement with the r option
enabled
and then anything that you put between
the submit and end submit lines will be
executed as our code rather than as SAS
code
now I mentioned that it's pretty easy to
move data back and forth between R and
SAS and if you want to go from R to SAS
you can use the import data set from our
subroutine
and if you want to go in the opposite
direction so to go from SAS to R use the
export data set to our subroutine
both of these subroutines use the exact
same syntax you start by specifying the
name of the SAS data set and then
specify the name of the r data frame
I mentioned before that this option
doesn't require admin privileges but
really that's only partially true
if you want to use this method from base
SAS then you don't need to have admin
privileges in order to enable this rlang
option
but if you're like me and if you prefer
to use an IDE like SAS Enterprise guide
then you will need admin privileges in
order to enable this feature
if you are interested in using this
method from within SAS Enterprise guide
there's a video on my YouTube channel
that goes through the full instructions
of how to set this up
the third option that I'm going to talk
about today is the one that is the most
complex but also the one that's the most
useful if what you really need is the
interoperability between SAS and R and
if you don't have admin privileges
and if you want to be working from
within our studio
and this is actually the approach that I
was using myself at work for the past
couple of months myself and a co-worker
on my team as well as a colleague from
another part of our organization worked
together to develop an internal art
package that contains a function that
allows you to take an R data frame
manipulate it in SAS and then return the
results to our as in our data frame
without ever leaving our studio
and this package is not publicly
available but you can easily come up
with a similar solution using the same
general underlying principles that I'm
about to show you
the first argument that this function
takes is the name of the r data frame
that you'd like to manipulate in SAS and
here I'm just using the Mt cars data set
which is a data set that comes built
into R and includes variables about
characteristics of cars such as miles
per gallon horsepower cylinders and so
on
the second argument that this function
takes is the location to the SAS
installation on your machine
and the final argument that this
function takes is the SAS code that
you'd like to apply to your R data frame
this function assumes that in SAS you
have access to a data set that's called
in underscore DF
and then the SAS data set that will
eventually get sent back to the user as
an R data frame is called out underscore
DF
and the example that I'm using here I'm
just using the frequency procedure in
SAS to create a frequency table of the
cylinder variable from the Mt cars data
set
and by executing just those two lines of
code the results from SAS are brought to
the user in rstudio without ever having
had to exit our studio
in terms of the actual implementation of
this function this function starts by
creating a temporary file folder and
then saving the r the user inputted R
data frame as a DOT RDS file in that
temporary file folder
from here a temporary SAS program is
created and the user inputted SAS code
is then inserted into that temporary SAS
program making use of proc IML and the
import data set from R and export data
set to our subroutines that we talked
about a little bit earlier
this temporary SAS program is then
executed by sending a command to the
command prompt
enabling the Arling option and then the
temporary files are deleted after the
results are brought back into our and
finally the results are returned to the
user as an R data frame
we all love R but there might be times
where we want or need to use other
programming languages
tools like saspy are making this easier
than ever to combine multiple languages
in the same place but if these options
are unavailable or infeasible to you for
whatever reason then you might be able
to find some clever workarounds if
you're willing to put in the work
for me it's been a little over a year of
exploring all these different options
and More in order to figure out what's
viable for me in my workplace and I'm
very happy to say that as of two weeks
ago some changes to our it
infrastructure have resulted in
statistics Canada employees being able
to use SAS Pi without any issues at all
thank you so much for listening I'd be
super happy to connect on LinkedIn or
wherever if you want to chat about this
more
[Music]